let fear be your guy
I'm stuck here at the edge
keep pushing
push yourself out yeah now bring your
lower hand up
okay well done Zach you've done the
harpy okay now just climb up
all right
[Music]
I'm on my way to pick up actor Zachary
Quinto and the Star Trek stop to spock
Zachary has a healthy sense of adventure
but as Zach he throwing the city's name
in
we're gonna help change that okay let's
do it there's ready
I am on an island off the coast of
Panama
I'm here to have an adventure with Bear
Grylls which is uh really exciting
getting some perspective from bear about
what it is to be in the wilderness and
living on the land is something that I'm
really interested in and excited about
no idea what today has been stormy I
don't know where we're going what we're
doing
what we're gonna eat
which is probably like the biggest beer
that I have but I feel like if there's
chickens it's a good omen
Emmy nominated actor Zachary Quinto has
been entertaining fans since the early
2000s after finding success on hit TV
shows he made the jump to the Silver
Screen where he captured the next
generation of Star Trek fans with his
portrayal of the iconic character Spock
engineering reports ready for lunch now
he's looking for a challenge only mother
nature can often so my hope is that this
journey can help me break out of its
comfort zone and defy all expectations
he has of himself
[Applause]
she's probably
emotions on Earth
[Applause]
oh all right I feel like I didn't expect
this
it's pretty amazing
it's not a sign of life around except
for the birds I'm really interested in
stepping outside of my comfort zone as I
get older I look for experiences to kind
of keep me curious and keep me pushing
myself all right so we should probably
check the uh
the backpack for some Clues
so that seems like a harness so maybe
there'll be some rappelling yeah that's
a uh
a grappling repeller
I could be making that up but how good
there's water
at least there's water so I don't have
to
drink my PE
a which is the thing right
see a helicopter
that can mean only one thing
Bear Grylls has arrived
[Music]
what's up man
how are you man nice to meet you buddy
great to be here
ready for an adventure yeah man okay
that's gonna be
quick check or looking good tonight
[Music]
foreign
seeing bear come in on the side rail of
the helicopter is always so exciting but
I had zero idea that I'd be riding the
side rail of the helicopter up here I
don't know it was just so such an
amazing way to get started I feel really
uh I feel really fired up okay so
mission for us
to reach the coast okay our extraction
points is about eight kilometers okay
but we do have a bit of a time pressure
on this we are in tropical storm season
there is a cyclone coming in we've got
under 12 hours to do this but we need to
be out of here by the time that hits
okay let's do it okay heading that way
the weather forecast says that Cyclone
is baroning through the Pacific and
heading for the remote island where
we've been dropped off in order to reach
our extraction point before nightfall
Zachary Quinto and I must follow our
Compass bearing 270 degrees Due West but
it won't be easy we'll have to navigate
deep Gorges with steep drop-offs and
Traverse River caves that can be home to
the deadliest of jungle predators
this is definitely getting dense which
means our navigation needs to be on
point still 270 degrees so looking at
this Compass you want to be going west
we want to be going with 270 degrees
eight kilometers we're about 1K in got
it so the other important stuff is
knowing how far we're going so we keep
the pace up and get out before the storm
hits right you're going to be in charge
of distance okay good wear measuring
distance in the jungle I would break it
down to little 10 meter sections so I
know from here to that rock over there
it's about 10 meters all right let me
see
this rock here so if you mentally
sort of adjust to that distance you know
that's 10 here you go measure if you
want
you think then my next right there seven
eight nine ten yeah okay so there you go
so if you collect 10 little Stones yeah
in a dense jungle keeping track of
distance traveled can be hard work so
we're gonna rely on a tried and true
navigation technique used by ancient
cultures and even today by the Special
Forces okay so those are for you so
every time we cover 10 meters one goes
into the other pocket every time we've
done ten we're done 100 meters all right
there's a thousand meters in a kilometer
once Zak has moved all 10 Pebbles into
his other pocket it means we've traveled
a hundred meters after completing this
10 times we will have traveled one
kilometer so we have we have seven more
to go seven more to go okay there you go
so you've started to do it without even
thinking you just see the 10 meters and
just as we're going and chatting is
happening all right
oh
[Music]
so where were you actually brought up uh
I grew up in Pittsburgh yeah and
brothers or sisters I got an older
brother
and he's much more uh inclined to the
outdoors than I am yeah I've done some
camping trips with him was he a partner
in crime growing up well he was seven
years older than I am so yeah we were
kind of far enough apart that we didn't
really become close until we were adults
and and you lost your dad didn't you
when you were yeah yeah my dad died when
I was seven he was also really into
fishing and outdoor stuff but it's such
a vulnerable age that wow seven what a
tough one for you yeah it is you know
and uh and it's informed everything
about my life I would say on some level
or another I didn't realize it for years
and years to come but my whole world
view is shaped on on my relationship to
death at such a young age and
obviously I would love to have my father
in my life but I know that he is in my
life still you know and there's
something really profound and for me
actually
beautiful about the way that that shaped
me you know painful though it was we are
I think as we move through this world
you know supported by
um by those angels you know that we
acquire along the way yeah um and he's
definitely one of them yeah well we will
need those angels yeah we might need
them today definitely lent on them many
times okay
just wash yourself on them yeah leaves
on top of rocks yeah and obviously where
you're putting your hands
wow
270 degrees still this way oh great
following your bearing at 270 degrees
but we have reached this place where
it's just a kind of dried out waterfall
in front of us you know normally you'd
only try and look for a way around this
the problem is it's just really loose
crumbling jungle wool did you get that
grappling hook yeah yeah if ever there
was a time for grappling hook this is
probably it so trying to throw a
grappling hook with a thick climbing
rope attach you it's just too much
weight to throw up there for tying a bit
of thin line to the grappling hook you
get it sned then you just pull a thin
line through attached to the climbing
rope and bingo you got two nice climbing
ropes to go okay so I reckon best way is
the old grenade overhead we're trying to
get it as high up that but that's all
really Jagged we'll get it jammed in
there great mine takes a few goes all
right so just uh overhand lob okay good
and big real massive launch
grenade launch out there
so good for bigger higher
that's good we're getting there that was
50 closer you know the truth is there's
no magic recipe to throwing a grappling
hook they remind you're dragging a rope
with it but like all things in the
jungle and survival we never give up
okay you've heard it is it Third Time
Lucky big go big
[Music]
okay now to see if that has held
oh we go if it comes back on you I mean
you're kind of screwed right well it's
not so much here it's when we're halfway
up all right I haven't done a lot of
rock climbing or repelling so that'll be
in uh kind of outside of my comfort zone
challenge but it looks it looks
manageable I think from down here anyway
we'll see what happens when we get up
there
so this feels awkward but the way this
works this can go up
but when you sit in it
so the awkward bit is the first bit of
getting you off the ground but you sit
in it yeah then you put your foot Loop
in yeah
and then you stand up and push it up
high got it the best way of climbing up
these things is use what's called a Juma
it's a simple climbing device slaps onto
the rope and will only allow you to go
up and then when you pull down it clamps
on itself so we can use one with a foot
strap one with just our hands an edge
our way up this rope definitely physical
uh but functional so when you get to the
wall Zach yeah you're gonna need to push
off a little bit Yeah Yeah
giving your way up
keep edging your way up one hand and the
other got it
it just it just makes it look so easy
you know he just makes it look like
another day in the jungle
but uh so it's coming down you ready
yeah here it goes
got it so the awkward bit will be the
first bit
until you get your feet on the rock
[Music]
push your foot Loops high as you can
hold on and then work your saddle one up
higher
ah
okay
well done
remembering that Cyclone hits the only
place worse than hanging on the end of a
rope
is going to be caught in a flash flood
fair enough yeah let's do it let fear be
your guide
definitely need to try and keep the pace
up here
I'm just aware of that storm
you know really we can't hang around too
long here
pushing
yes that's it you're almost sad
[Music]
okay so push yourself out
so left leg up now bring your lower one
up your lower hand
well on Zach you've done the hard bit
okay now just climb up got it got it got
it okay
all right
[Music]
keep pushing Zach yeah let's do it
let fear be your guide actor Zachary
Quinto and I are fighting away through a
dense Panama jungle and right now my
biggest concern is getting safely up
this huge crumbling Cliff okay now just
climb up
the hard part is getting past the
overhang so there you go get back on
your feet nice wide stance all the power
through your feet and your legs
there you go there you go beautiful
good job oh my Lord I think my grappling
hook throw is a little better than my
climb but I've never really done that
before it took me a couple minutes I got
some encouragement
eventually I made it not easy you
definitely showed your Warrior Spirit on
that one yeah what do you think that
Warrior Spirit come from in your life
I think learning how to survive
from a young age has a lot to do with it
I mean as an actor you active fight
every day deal with rejection and yeah
but I think you have to have a certain
uh mentality going into it so I think
there were there were factors in my life
that led me to
my journey as an actor that had nothing
to do with acting or creativity didn't
you have a bad like car accident
it almost killed you I was 16 then it
was the first time my mom gave me the
car to drive on my own after I got my
license and so I was feeling all full of
myself and went and picked up some
friends and it was in the middle of
winter and hit a patch of black ice at
60 miles an hour narrowly missed a
telephone pole narrowly missed a you
know big giant oak tree luckily nobody
was hurt but the gravity of the
situation was clearly apparent
I think it just made me realize what was
important to me that I had found this
thing that I didn't want to compromise
on that I wanted to pursue I wanted to
go to school for for acting and that was
something that was always a bit Up For
Debate in my family I think that moment
you know I fought for something because
I realized what I could have lost yeah
you know it's funny how our lives have
pivotal moments that sometimes give us a
little nudge and a little bit of courage
to actually follow what you
you know is right but it's scary and
difficult sometimes yeah
well we better keep moving Sky's looking
a little dodgy over there eh yeah
how are we doing for the
the pacing we're about halfway there
three and a half kilometers three and a
half yeah really you've been counting
that right yeah I hope I am completely
making it up I counted the first 10
meters and then we just get to talking
and like find stuff and like I can't
move the I still have the stones in my
pocket but I've stopped moving them from
one pocket to the next don't tell bear
I think he knows I think he's on to me
what would you say I'd say like two tops
really
you've been doing it right yeah every 10
meters yeah Zach's pacing I'm a little
bit dubious how accurate it is we have
got quite a lot of ground to cover so
we're gonna keep the pace up and get out
before the storm hits I'm trusting you
you're in charge of that we're in charge
you're 270. here we go let's go
I think
oh look at all this there's nasty stuff
so easy to be moving along and you kind
of reach out for something look if you
put your hand off reach out for that and
let all of it all the way up at this
stuff one of things was seeing a ton of
in this jungle in these black Palms
soldiers call them bastard trees because
if you put your hand on it the spike
goes straight through and it's like ah
faster so as you can see up there yeah
there's that's a black palm fruit that
is edible but right it's well protected
yeah the black palm tree is native to
Central and South America and can reach
50 feet tall when fully grown the large
spikes that surrounds and protects its
fruit from predators can break off in
the skin and cause bacterial infections
so harvesting the fruit is no easy task
unless you've got a machete so they come
around here without a grabbing hold of
anything
even here see all these little hairs
yeah
so they see all those little hairs here
oh yeah so those are really nasty to get
in here
wow it looks just like the fruit that
contains cyanide that can kill you so
easy to get it wrong great no this is
good
it's almost like grapes hmm what the
humble bastard tree takes on One Hand by
shredding you if you grab hold of it it
gives with the other
that's good there's a good fruit that's
good that's definitely replenish us
giving a bit of sugars and energy to
keep moving
you're right Zach yeah how the Pebbles I
feel like we're coming up on four
kilometers now oh yes
okay watch yourself here
yeah look we're gonna
270 degrees so we've reached a point
where really we need to keep going on
the same bearing the problem is there's
a sheer drop ahead of us uh down to a
ravine we've got running water in there
but really it's where we need to go it's
just a question of how to get down there
I think just use the rope yeah
around the tree yeah repel off get down
into that and then we can follow that
because really that is our Direction
that's already yeah
so have you ever repelled before no okay
so two things matter one is what you're
tying off to but that is strong yeah and
two is that you never let go that way
sure
so I've got enough rope to be able to
put it around the tree both of us repel
off it but truth be told it's not a
rookies repel this but we're gonna go
together he'll see me go first and he'll
be fine so Zach yeah it's a nice wide
stance I've got an overhang here okay
lean right back
and take your time and when you're ready
to go
a little jump in like that okay and
always keep your hand on that breaker so
just never let go never let go
nice and steady here
it seems a little easier as he gets
closer to the bottom
like the scary bit feels like it's going
to be up top
feels a little crazy to me but I'm gonna
go for it okay Zach if you get yourself
in position
working on it
all right wide stance
okay
uh there you go that's it trust it
great job well done beautiful
well done Zach here hey so good you're
nailing it
beautiful
great job really great yeah that's all
good yeah that was more fun than going
up I will say yeah I was more nervous at
the top once I like got over the
overhang I felt really good about it it
felt good to trust myself I feel good to
trust the equipment it felt good to
trust Fair it felt good to like
you know I don't know accomplish that
okay so we're gonna follow this
for as long as we can as long as it's
heading in the right direction for us
we're going to keep following it as you
can see it's a lot of water coming down
there so I really really want to hang
around here
oh
so when the storm hits this Gully this
whole thing is Gonna Fill up so we're
gonna pick up the pace of it because
we're in a river valley there's the risk
of flash floods so we don't really want
to be around these parts okay it's not
really slippery the Rocks underneath
just take your time so that storm is
definitely approaching we've had kind of
moments where the wind suddenly really
picks up and that is indicative that
there is a front moving this way we do
not want to be in this Ravine when the
rain's hit
oh wow
it's a dead end
massive Boulders are blocking this River
oh look and with nowhere to go the water
is working its way underground where
does that go
if the river is going to be our guide
Zach and I may have to head down into
this cave just wash your foot in their
own and drop into that yeah right if
anyway it's going to be snake City it's
these sort of things is that right let's
just have a look at this
maybe use a rope I'd go and see what
it's like all looks good as long as it's
got a way out what I'm nervous of you go
in the current cell's picking you up
gets narrower and so we will use a rope
so we have a method of retreat
can we use a rope I go and see what it's
like all is good
as long as it's got a way out what I'm
nervous of you go in the current cell's
picking you up and gets narrower and
then it should I mean you can't go back
against it so we will use a rope so we
have a method of retreat
let's do I'm gonna try and go just over
that Boulder there Zachary Quinto and I
are deep in the Panama jungle following
a river but it's blocked ahead by
Massive Boulders get over that if the
river is going to be our guide it's
pretty solid yeah we have to head again
into this cave hand over hand yeah slow
yourself down you're not really secured
okay so you've really got to climb it
okay that's a nice foothold so
there
you all right down there
okay so I'll stay down here so I should
come down yeah keep real good hold
really good hold that's it and then keep
your feet where they are and lower
yourself down a bit you're almost on the
ground there you go okay so we can pull
this rope through now
[Music]
okay here we go
wow
pretty cool
[Music]
oh
what's your head
who am I said
[Music]
just really watch your footing is set
right it's pretty hard terrain still
over there
oh
there's some fish really really good
sized fish
look look there's another one oh yeah
that's a good sign though we've got fish
here we have actually seen a load of
fish in this River so we could maybe try
and make something that's going to allow
us to catch some food because I think
both of us at this stage are hungry
needing a bit of energy
good thank you
oh look
oh well
it's a bit stinking yeah it's like
oh yeah yeah often times in a jungle
environment like this dead animals can
be found along Riverbanks this lizard
probably died somewhere upstream and
then floated down but we could use it
for
use it for bait we end up fishing
that would be good
found a dead lizard rotted and
disgusting and putrid if you turn around
and put it in your backpack the lizard
you're putting the lizard in my backpack
aren't you at first I thought we were
going to get away with just leaving it
where it was but uh bear being bare that
wasn't really an option so he put it in
my backpack just lost his tail here you
go foreign
poor thing
following this River saved us a lot of
time and we've made good progress but
it's starting to head south and Zach and
I need to keep moving 270 degrees Due
West in order to reach our extraction
point on the coast
well smell the lizard yeah
whoa
that was a bad day for a pilot that's
crazy
come down in the jungle you're probably
not going to walk away from that
but for the Survivor definitely worth
checking out
but that is probably a drug run you
think it was yeah they still the runs
straight across Panama that's crazy
I mean look at this
I know there's loads in here that we can
use you know look at all this wire
you know we could use this as a fishing
line
maybe try and see if we make a proper
fishing rod out of some of this stuff
maybe have a stop here make a little far
get dry
see if we can catch something to eat
we've got the lizard we can use that as
bait
just be careful if we got the spiders
okay I'll let you get this out all right
okay I'm gonna have a little look around
here for the Survivor is this plane
wreck but it's a great resource you know
it's going to be full of wire and metal
and all sorts of kind of things we're
going to take some time see what we can
scavenge get a fire going get some to
weed and then push on towards the end
oh look at these guys what look
cockroaches
look at look these are good yeah they're
good for you can actually just eat I
know you can please don't is that one
you're worth it it's my thing you know
what I mean I try to play it cool but I
really hate cockroaches have ever since
I was a little kid it's like the one
thing that I'm like I have a phobia of
them I just hate them well look I'm
gonna keep these
I don't need them in my pockets so like
I was totally fine letting him handle
those
should we get this look this uh
there yeah that's a flare well this is a
good way to start the fight right
clearly right Zach has found a hand
flare there's so much you can do with
flares you can signal for help obviously
but also do things like Starting Fire
protect yourself against wild animals so
good find Zach and that maybe is that
can be our fishing rod great line yeah
that's good so the plan for fishing is
just I've cut a little bit of wire
so here we go that'll work it's a hook
Zach has stripped a load of the
electrical cable out that we're going to
use for the fishing line tied it around
a stick a bit of the rotting guts from
that lizard I knew that would come in
handy okay so here we go
a bit of his guts out
okay so if you reach for a bit of that
you smell it I don't want to smell
it
okay yep
thanks
give it a guts
do you still have cockroaches in your
pocket yeah
okay so a little bit of the stinky guts
yeah that's great bait let's take that
down to the river
[Music]
Okay so
like that
bait's floating on there
nice little shaded area
this is good all right okay
I would love to catch a fish
that would be a real like notch on the
survivalist belt if we could catch a
fish with things that we found in a
plane wreck okay we've got a flare a
bunch of Tinder bunch of kindling and
then we'll get this going great okay so
put this like that hold that in take
that off
and then all you gotta do is pull that
okay and it's gonna not do anything for
a couple of seconds don't look down it
okay okay and then it's gonna go crazy
and this will probably get hot and
everything so as soon as you pull it
just stick it in there okay okay
foreign
[Music]
we got a size it's in the wrong place
oh and a black palm
so welcome to the jungles what happens
everything always goes wrong but it's
good we'll get this on there
and we got fire
well done
oh I love it good job
[Music]
yeah look really
no way
finish this guy off
oh wow
you got right into that huh oh
there it is good job yeah okay let's cut
him and we'll put him on the Fire
of course you have to gut the fish this
is the part of it that I'm always a
little like
get your hands into this pull out all
those guts
this is my urban city living vibes
but you know I think it's important to
see how this stuff happens and be a part
of it if you can
you know what we can do right so look we
get the cockroach
get the guts out of that we're gonna put
him inside there and we're going to cook
it up that will add a bit of cockroach
flavor to it delicious yeah nice I guess
I'm gonna eat some cockroach marinated
fish we'll see
okay so look put the fish on a bit of
the aluminum from the tail
let's put that on there
cook it up perfect amazing and then like
infused with cockroach great
so what was what was like your journey
you ever been a such a strong powerful
Champion for gay rights yeah does that
be that's obviously being a huge part of
your life yeah definitely advocating on
behalf of young people especially
um has been really important to me it's
so much has changed so quickly actually
in in the lgbtq community and a lot of
it for the better but not all of it and
there's still a lot of work to be done
um and so I feel like yeah you know
being visible
being engaged doing good work and being
a good person these are all the
Hallmarks of the kind of life that I
want to live so that so that who I am
and what my sexual orientation is is
just one part of that you know like
because I can't imagine how hard that
must be is it how old were you when you
came out
um
well I was 24 when I came out to my
family so that's that's quite old yeah I
mean that's the it's interesting you
know so I I'm of a different generation
yeah you know so when did you know I
mean I knew when I was
seven eight nine yeah and I would say
you know I spent a long time
believing it wasn't true or wishing it
wasn't true but uh but it was a slow
process for me and then and then I
graduated from school and I you know I
was out to my friends and my family but
I wasn't out in my in my work you know I
was terrified I was still of that of
that era where it was like really
considered uh
really you know it was dangerous and you
know it was living during that era in
like the early 2000s when like people
were you know there was like all those
gossip Rags that were outing people and
all of that and so you know my journey
professionally then took another seven
years I didn't come out uh until
uh yeah until 2011 so when I came out
publicly
and and I you know there was there was a
whole string of uh of teenage suicides
in the United States at the time
um all these kids were killing
themselves because they were getting
bullied and one kid in particular I had
found out and he had made and it gets
better video
um and then months later took his own
life I just woke up one day and read
that and I was like oh yeah okay well I
can't hide behind this anymore I can't
live the life that I'm living and not
say the words you know so um so that was
that was my path did and was it hard for
you as a teenager I got bullied as a kid
I went to an all-boys uh private
Catholic High School so they got bullied
a lot actually but I responded to it in
this way where I found my power in the
face of bullying you know I actually
found that like the thing that people
are making fun of me for is the thing
that makes me special it's the thing
that makes me different it's the thing
that makes me unique it's the thing that
makes me powerful yes the thing that
makes you stronger yeah and I put all of
that into my work and into what I love
because I mean I got bullied a lot for
being like the drama
kid you know I kind of used it as fuel
in a way where are the bullies now would
be my question well they're certainly
not in my life you know what I mean and
that's the interesting things I mean
it's the one thing that I like try to
tell young people all the time it's like
these voices will be silenced because
you'll just grow outgrow them you'll
find your way out of where you are and I
know I did what a powerful statement you
are that is good and an inspiration to
so many
thanks I mean I feel really blessed for
that I really do
for you
try the fish yeah man looks good
Okay so
oh first of all there's the cockroach
that's for you buddy
yeah that is truly terrible is it yeah
that's the low point of the meal very
good and here's a high point
hmm it's really good yeah it's amazing
how things taste better when you've
really had to work for them
and that was good really good well done
well what I knew today
we've still got
to get moving to get out of here
how far have we got I know the bearing
270s that way I think we've got another
kilometer to go
I've also got a great nose but
all I know is we're going to keep moving
we had seven to start with right you
said we'd gone two so that was five
we've probably gone two and a half since
then I mean I lost count of all the
stones it becomes difficult to measure
every 10 meters when you're like you
know Traders either
all I know is we gotta we gotta push on
all right the sun is dipping yeah and we
cannot miss our extract yeah great all
right I'm down so we're almost at our
extraction point now the last push
according to Zach's pacing we only have
a kilometer to go so we're making really
good time we're almost there then you
stomp the fire out yeah
okay you need to pick up the pace sack
all right
keep counting
coming up
what this is crazy
okay Zach you can do it
home is on the other side so it's my
only choice
they hear waves yeah that's a good sign
yeah Zach and I are close to our
extraction point but a nearby tropical
storm is about to make a landfall so
there's no time to waste here you go
first side of the sea
wow look at that wow so beautiful big
old waves smashing in
there you go the coast is amazing good
job so cool oh extraction isn't here
it's over on that rock Pinnacle there so
between here and there
is a little bit of a gap all right and
that's our Helix strength you know we
manage the gas and we're 22 minutes
until the helicopter's inbound so I've
preset something up here because I knew
we were going to be fighting time we're
going to get there work fast go together
get it done great you ready yeah
be careful on this Edge
so ropes are still in place
helicopter couldn't basically get in
here but in tickle on right on the end
of that Pinnacle what we're going to do
clip on yeah and
once we put weight on it it will sag a
bit so the first half will be okay
gravity will do the work but then he's
gonna get physical then and that's
probably 200 foot across this will be a
grueling 200 foot terrillion Traverse my
plan is to lead the way once on the
other side Zach will have to retrieve
the pulley system secure himself and
then muscle across the line suspended
high above the jagged rocks below
it will be Hardware I'll go first and
see how I do it okay and then you follow
okay the quickest way is the straightest
way so there you go
it looks fun
I think it's going to be pretty
terrifying out over the over the
crashing waves in on the rocks
okay so Zach on this bit
just walk yourself out it drops off here
okay you will drop down yeah okay so
uh that looks crazy
I don't know how I feel about it now
maybe I should have gone first okay so
it's got me most of the way here
there's still about a hundred foot to
the end this bit is going to be all
about a biceps so at this point you're
gonna have to pull yourself
yeah this is definitely gonna be
hard work for Zach
Mary and Joseph
okay Zach
uh
now I'm technically
I think officially
nervous but home is on the other side so
it's my only choice
Strong finish let's do it Zach make sure
you keep your fingers out of the pulley
Roger that just hold on to your harness
trust it
[Laughter]
this is terrifying actually now
you're good you can do it
all right I mean what this is crazy
I'm really scared okay
you could do it Zach
you can do it okay
oh I don't know man
I gotta do it right
just walk yourself down and trust it
let's go
[Music]
this is crazy so at this point you're
gonna have to pull yourself
oh my Lord
well done Zach good effort hello there
well done just muscle it out last 10
feet
thank you
oh amazing amazing man it was one thing
to see bear do it it was another thing
to walk up to the edge of that cliff and
step off I definitely
feel like
you know I went I went above some
thresholds today yeah it was cool
respect Yeah man they lost me come with
me all right so definitely feel the wind
is picking up now we're probably only an
hour or so away from that big Cyclone
hitting but we've made the coast we're
on time pop the smoke give it a pull a
big grenade and see throw it over there
helicopter zimban and we're gonna be out
of here before that storm hits well done
okay I can hear it
bear I can't thank you enough for an
incredible Adventure I challenged myself
in ways that I could never have imagined
I would come here
like you said it's so easy to take
things for granted and get complacent in
our Urban lives but coming out of the
Jungle of Panama with you made me
realize and remember how important it is
to stay connected to our world
thanks for having me
this journey has been such a fun one for
me Zachary Quinto is a man who has had
to overcome so many obstacles and
Prejudice within his life but I think
what is most telling for me is that
through it all he has kept such a good
heart and also a great sense of humor
and that carries anyone a long way what
a hero for now
exactly amazing
[Music]